bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag avec
l'élargissement du territoire saint
quentin en yvelines devient le premier
pôle commercial du département une place
de numéro un qui impose aujourd'hui de
concevoir une stratégie globale et
cohérente à l'échelle du territoire et
qui répondent aux besoins des
populations
je vous emmène donc faire vos emplettes
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
une nouvelle force est né à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis le 1er
janvier 2016 une force commerciale
élargie à 12 communes de l'agglomération
concentre désormais plus de 2400
commerces et services
cette marché et 193 grande surface
répartis sur plus de 300 mille mètres
carrés pour un chiffre d'affaires de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros par an le
free et diversifiée 20% est concentrée
dans le secteur commercial 16% dans le
secteur des cafés et restaurants 15%
dans l'équipement de la personne
quinze autres % dans les services non
commerciaux 11% dans l'alimentaire neuf
dans l'automobile neuf encore en culture
et loisirs et 4% dans l'équipement de la
maison
une offre pléthorique qui permet
d'éviter l'évasion économique
85% des saint quentinois font leurs
achats sur le territoire un territoire
qui propose deux pôles majeurs alpha
parc aux clayes-sous-bois et la zone
commerciale grand plaisir à plaisir
maison du monde castorama boulanger
alinéa ou encore celio alpha parc a
ouvert ses portes en 2006 construit à
taille humaine pour plus de convivialité
le projet mis en oeuvre par la compagnie
phalsbourg s'est vu décerner le prix va
leur part pour la qualité de son
architecture
le site a aussi reçu la qualification
haute qualité environnementale
tout ce centre il est vraiment tourné
sur l'aménagement de la maison il avait
été prévu qui est pas d'alimentaire sur
ce centre parce qu'on voulait pas faire
concurrence à nos collègues de plaisir
que déjà eu beaucoup de beaucoup de
d'alimentaire et puis je pense que c'est
pas bien de le mélanger à l'exception du
bio lassé nature est ok l'exception sur
le projet mais on n'est plus beaucoup
tourner sur l'équipement la maison sur
ce qui explique pas c'est à dire le
loisir sur les restaurants avec la place
gourmande et une émulation avec ikea
avec but qui fait de ce secteur plaisir
les clayes-sous-bois finalement un
secteur où il ya énormément non
[Musique]
juste en face la zone commerciale de
plaisir elle concentre le centre
commercial auchan et moult grand magasin
ikea décathlon ou toysrus la halle ça a
été réfléchie de façon à ce que il ya
une circulation quand même qui
permettent de vivre à proximité
sa porte aussi bien sur une dynamique
commerciale ça apporte sig l'emploi
puisque sur plaisir nous n'avons que 7%
de chômage mais plaisir réserve encore
bien des surprises pour 2018 les
développements qui vont avoir lieu ici
un juste derrière moi avec open sky va
effectivement apporté une une démarche
supplémentaire commercial mais qui est
en complémentarité ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce qui se fait de l'autre côté
commerces restaurants et salles de
cinéma y sont attendus on est
véritablement dans cette démarche est
une démarche non pas purement
commerciale mais de lieu de vie avec des
endroits beaucoup d' espaces verts à
l'intérieur du centre
et aussi cette possibilité d'être à la
fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
profitant du projet auchan et sa
périphérie seront relookées afin de
s'insérer davantage dans ce nouveau
paysage un relooking qui a déjà commencé
avec le doublement de la rd 30 qui
permettra de fluidifier la circulation
le territoire compte également un pôle
commercial de bassin avec espace saint
quentin sky os et le canal à montigny le
bretonneux
créée en 1987 espace saint quentin a été
totalement intégré au coeur de la ville
nouvelle et des habitations
chaque année c'est 13 millions de
visiteurs qui parcourent les allées du
centre commercial
il ya différentes actions qui vont nous
permettre justement de maintenir
l'attractivité en tout cas de maintenir
le dynamisme du centre commercial espace
saint quentin
le premier c'est la rénovation qui a eu
lieu en 2014 dont nous avons rénové la
totalité du centre aussi bien sur ces
parties intérieures que ces parties
extérieures
le deuxième on accorde une importance
relativement élevé au développement de
services dans le centre dernièrement ont
été mises en place des bornes de
recharge mobile dans des casiers
sécurisé mais aussi des consignes pour
les casques moto les clients ont aussi
la possibilité de retirer en magasin
leurs achats réalisés sur internet le
site continue également d'accueillir de
nouvelles enseignes
ces douze derniers mois burger king
pandora's zahrobsky ou encore bialetti
se sont installés plusieurs magasins ont
aussi été rénové orange
h&m ou encore un jour ailleurs récemment
le centre commercial a développé une
application mobile pour signaler les
promotions et les jeux concours et pour
aider les clients à s'orienter dans
espace saint quentin
mais l'attractivité ne s'arrête pas là
la rue piétonne c'est une est une vraie
force pour notre centre commercial parce
que c'est un élément différenciant par
rapport aux autres centres commerciaux
et on connaît très peu de centres
commerciaux qui sont dotés d'un espace
intérieur et relais respect secteur
comme espace 50 ans tout près skywest
déserté par les enseignes à l'exception
du cinéma ugc ciné cité et de quelques
restaurants devraient bientôt renaître
de ses cendres
les 7000 m² seront comblés par des
activités de loisirs au programme
fitness simulation de formule 1 et
culture autre pause économique du
territoire
la zone de maurepas coignières avec par
west le gibet et les portes de chevreuse
et quatre pôles intermédiaires les 7 mar
à elancourt lemay renter à voisins le
bretonneux
le centre commercial des
clayes-sous-bois s'ajoute à cela dit
cette poule secondaires ou de relais
au total le territoire représente 1300
m² de surface commerciale par habitant
soit le double de surface de la moyenne
hexagonale
une activité qui représente 30 % de
l'emploi des yvelines
mais au fait les saint quentinois sont
plutôt centres commerciaux aux commerces
de proximité mais si tu fais un temps
comme aujourd'hui je suis plus commerces
de proximité et petit marché qui gît bon
bah on est servi avec le sourire
par des gens sympathiques les grands
hypermarchés ont ils vraiment trop de
temps donc je suis plutôt aux commerces
de proximité pour mes courses
alimentaires je vais utiliser les drive
va le marché par exemple les fruits et
légumes
oui plutôt marchés de proximité dans les
commerces de proximité
on sait la boulangerie le boucher c'est
plus rapide on trouve tout de suite ce
qu'on veut et on est familiarisé plutôt
viande d'équations commerces de
proximité et l'épicerie en grande
surface
quand voilà le temps ne s'y prête pas je
gère effectivement le centre d'auto
mersen saint-quentin décathlon ou
toysrus là vous avez quai en face ici
donc ces cas nettement plus pratique
d'avoir tout sous la main il est 9h à
plaisir katiana le fiac ouvre les portes
de l'atelier pressing suffit de
commerçante et ma maman est installé
dans le même centre commercial que
celui-ci et j'ai vu vraiment l'émergence
de chant et l'agrandissement de chants
et de sa galerie marchande et la
disparition de ce fait d'eux des
commerçants du centre-ville nettoyé
merci à tout à l'heure en bas on peut
rester attractif par le lien concret
avec notre clientèle c'est surtout ça en
fait je pense essentiellement parce que
vous avez tout leflux de la clientèle
qui dirigeait vers les grandes surfaces
aussi bien les infrastructures routières
comme l'indication des grandes de ces
grandes surfaces l'a donc effectivement
vous avez des consommateurs qui prennent
des habitudes de consommation et pour
nous c'est vraiment très difficile de
les de les faire revenir vers nous à
part par le lien social et le service
rendu et effectivement les commerces de
proximité source de vie des centres
villes et lien social pour les habitants
une richesse à entretenir comme
l'évoquent les commerçants de villes pro
le commerce de proximité peu
résistez 1
aux grands centres commerciaux alentours
grâce à une
concertation avec les élus sur la
répartition de ces grands centres
commerciaux et des différents petits
commerces qui peuvent être implantés
dans les villes
je pense qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
diriger une ville sans qu'ils aient une
collaboration participative
servane 24 ans et demi je suis à
villepreux dont ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'effectivement je connais
beaucoup de familles et je connais aussi
les enfants
des familles puisque j'ai vu les petits
bambino il y avait deux ans et
maintenant effectivement ils ont 22 23
ans et c'est ce qui fait le charme de
justement de la proximité
nous avons non seulement un rôle
économique mais aussi un rôle social
voire même un rôle culturel
nous souhaitons encore une fois que les
administrés que levin prochain à
villecroze yen puisse rencontrer leurs
commerçants les acteurs économiques de
leur ville
parce que eux connaissent leur prénom
connaissent leurs enfants donc il ya
quand même un lien social qui est
important est une vraie discussion à
avoir plus tôt avec avec les élus de
manière à faire évoluer les communes
dans le bon sens il faut vraiment qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble à une vision
d'entreprise a une vision de commerce
dans les centres villes des élus qui
semblent attachés à cette proximité avec
les commerçants il n'est pas question je
suis ferme là dessus pour que les
cowboys les commerces de proximité se
retrouvent en difficulté je souhaite
qu'il perdure et même qu'il se développe
je crois que c'est important on a besoin
des deux on le soutient mais c'est
extrêmement c'est extrêmement compliqué
c'est difficile maintenant d'être
d'autres commerçants il gagne sa vie
les associations de commerçants
permettent pour ces derniers d'adopter
une démarche commune pour se faire
connaître
créer des animations tout au long de
l'année et fidéliser les clients
des actions qui peuvent faire la
différence les maires sont aussi à pied
d'oeuvre aux clayes-sous-bois le marché
est en reconstruction pour encourager
les rencontres et la convivialité à
plaisir depuis trois ans la ville a
demandé le soutien de la chambre de
commerce par le biais d'un manager de
ville et une association de commerçants
a vu le jour
la commune va aussi mettre en place une
étude du centre bourg pourrait
développer la circulation douce et
cyclables afin d'agrémenter et
accompagner le commerce de proximité
le commerce de proximité c'est aussi les
marchés ils sont sept sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines à ouvrir
leurs portes à ciel ouvert chaque
semaine et tous les week-ends rencontre
[Musique]
ambiance chaleureuse et conviviale
c'est la carte maîtresse des marchés les
achats à ciel ouvert ajoute au
dépaysement fromager bouchers
poissonniers maraîchers diversité des
produits et accueil personnalisé
ici le contact humain prime les marchés
aux deux rôles importants un rôle de
lien social
ça permet aux gens déjà de se rencontrer
les uns les autres c'est aussi un lien
social ou un élément important pour les
municipalités qui profitent de pouvoir
rencontrer dans un contexte moins
structuré leur administrait on a chacun
notre clientèle qui vient qui vient le
mercredi comme ici pour pour faire la
poire et le samedi ou le dimanche pour
faire les courses pour la semaine dans
un centre commercial
le client n'est qu'un numéro sur une
carte ou ici c'est un visage un nom des
habitudes des gens que l'on que l'on
connaît on sait ce qu'ils prennent on
sait ce qui ce qu'ils aiment et on leur
donne aussi des conseils de mes concerts
on échange des recettes de cuisine
nous voici à one nation centre
commercial outlet où se côtoient une
centaine de commerces parmi les plus
grandes marques de luz ce site complète
l'offre du territoire en y accueillant
un public international
le territoire qui vient justement de
terminer son diagnostic concernant la
vie commerciale saint-quentinoise
alors quelle sera la nouvelle synergie
entre les divers acteurs et les
collectivités réponse qu'il faut
pérenniser nos zones commerciales
actuelles travailler sur la qualité sans
les étendre davantage parce que sinon on
va arriver à la cannibalisation son
appel ou des friches commerciales
il s'agit désormais de restaurer
l'existant en créant des espaces de vie
où les visiteurs pourront se promener
faire une pause repas partagé un instant
de vie
le projet ton aussi à soutenir le
commerce de proximité en fédérant les
associations de commerçants entre elles
et en les aidant dans leurs animations
et actions commerciales marketing direct
brainstorming entre commerçants idées
partagées sans oublier l'amélioration de
la visibilité et la signalétique les
meilleurs en plein des tirs l'urbanisme
l'éclairage la propreté des aides à la
façade moi même sur mon territoire je
vais aider des commerçants à aménager
leurs façades à investir dans
l'immobilier ou à la reprise d'activité
pour justement favoriser le commerce
local et chacun son rôle
l'agglomération agira sur les zones
commerciales et les merdes dans la
collectivité
mais il faut veiller avec eux avoir une
complémentarité entre les commerces de
proximité et les zones commerciales
c'est tout l'enjeu aussi du diagnostic
est engagé la majorité des besoins du
territoire sont comblés tout à fait donc
il est tout ce qu'il faut sur 50 ans
tout ce qu'il faut donc à saint quentin
en yvelines pour y faire vos achats de
fêtes que je vous souhaite d'excellentes
ciao
[Musique]